Mitsubishi is celebrating its 100th
anniversary as an automaker by coming
out with a special edition 100 of the
space star multi-purpose vehicle in 1917
Mitsubishi introduced the Model A
Japan's first series production car
since then the core of the company's
output has been small family friendly
vehicles the sixth generation space star
is primarily aimed at younger drivers
and autotest arena's faithfully says the
space star is an ideal first car for
novice drivers the name implies that
there's lots of room inside now eNOS is
going to take a look at some of the cars
other advantages she likes the stylish
design the radiator grille has a 3d
design the dynamic accents on the front
end include distinctively shaped edges
and curves on the hood and a big chrome
bar on the rear skirt the speech star is
3.8 meters long the extras on the
edition 100 plus model include these
cool alloy wheels optional sensors make
parking a breeze in the back there's a
roof spoiler with an integrated brake
light
[Music]
the space star is powered by a three
cylinder gasoline-powered engine with a
displacement of either one or one point
two liters the engine has a maximum
torque of 4,000 rpm this vehicle is
perfect for zipping around in city
traffic eNOS is testing a space star
with the more powerful of the two engine
options it's not a high powered vehicle
but it can hold its own on the freeway
eNOS doesn't care much for the clutch
pedal though because it's hard to figure
out how it works at first and it has
kind of a spongy feeling that could be
difficult for younger drivers to deal
with the space start does not offer a
particularly dynamic driving experience
on the other hand it doesn't use much
fuel we didn't get the 4.3 liters per
100 kilometers that the manufacturer
promises our test model came in at 5
liters but that's still pretty efficient
the chrome and the polish piano lacquer
on the steering wheel and the fixtures
give the interior a classy look and
contrast to the hard plastic that seems
to be just about everywhere younger
drivers will appreciate the smartphone
access and the space start comes
complete with heated seats in front
[Music]
and ahead
eNOS likes the cars electrically powered
retractable roof
then that makes the vehicle feel like a
convertible and that's particularly nice
on sunny days that spots are : the
bottom line is that the mitsubishi space
star is a comfortable vehicle that's
easy to drive
[Music]
enos points out that younger drivers are
often intimidated by mountainous terrain
Mitsubishi deals with that in this car
by adding Hill holder technology which
keeps the vehicle from sliding backward
when the brake pedal is released
overall the space stars design is
uncluttered
this indicator on the dashboard shows
which driving mode is being used
[Music]
that's what Tina says the seats in the
front are quite comfortable plus there's
enough room in the back to seat one
adult comfortably but only for short
hops
she says that the four pedals are easy
to reach but adults should test sit in
this car first because you can't move
the driver's seat back further than this
you can also raise the driver's seat and
that's unusual for an economy car but
there's still not much Headroom on the
other hand there's lots of room in the
trunk you can make more room by folding
over the rear seats
[Music]
damnit Sabina says that the Mitsubishi
space star has a lot to offer younger
drivers it's a good first car it doesn't
use a lot of fuel and it's fun to drive
even more experienced drivers will
discover that this is a solid vehicle
that delivers the goods but it's not
going to make your heart skip a beat
when you take it out on the road beaten
can Abba Biden having that kind of a
glaciers has clubs in Oslo Lincoln